the wilcoxon test analyzes whether  there's a difference between two  dependent samples or not in dependent  samples the measured values are always  available in pairs the pairs result from  for example repeated measures of the  same person therefore if you have two  dependent groups you want to test  whether there is a difference between  these two groups then you can use the  wilcoxon test the wilcoxon test is the  non-parametric counterpart of the t-test  for dependent samples to put it simple  if your data is not normally distributed  you use a non-parametric test in the  case of two dependent samples this would  be the wilcoxon test